Mexico demands Biden give amnesty to 10
million illegal immigrants in exchange
for help with border crisis a record
high of 300,000 illegal immigrants were
processed by Customs and Border
Protection in December it's criminal
they're criminals and now Joe Biden's
likely going I I'm willing to bet no
matter what happens this year be it
Biden or Trump Biden rubber stamp some
kind of amnesty 10 million illegal
immigrants instantly being granted
amnesty will forever change this country
and there is nothing you can do
understand this you why is it that the
bid Administration has been trafficking
illegal immigrants to all of these
different cities what did we see with Co
we saw the more conservative-minded
individuals fleeing to Texas and Florida
Florida turns deep red everybody comes
out and says oh Ronda sandis you're the
greatest Governor I did a good job but
let's let's also consider the fact that
with all of these people moving into
Miami moving into Florida for Refuge
that has stri ripped away a large
portion of the more right-leaning voters
and voter base in these places which
will now be replaced by illegal
immigrants who are being trafficked into
Chicago into New York into these liberal
places the first thing that it will do
is in the in in the in this census in
the next census it will give an
imbalance of power to Democrats it is
estimated that California has between
one and maybe even as high as seven
extra congressional seats and electoral
votes based on illegal immigrant
population because the census calculates
all people not all citizens and
congressional seats represent people not
citizens that's insane I think it was
Thomas Massie who said he has an
amendment to make it so that Congress
only represents citizens with 10 million
illegal immigrants coming into this
country and being shipped all over Joe
Biden can rubber stamp amnesty and
executive order it'll be unopposed there
will be challenges I'm sure but for the
most part no everyone's going to sit
back and watch and what's going to
happen happen is these people will
instantly start registering and you you
are basically giving Democrats a massive
majority in the voting block if amnesty
happens this right here Mexico demanding
it will be the justification for why Joe
Biden does give them amnesty and and
he'll say he'll say exactly what Ronald
Reagan did we're going to secure the
Border we're going to enforce our laws
and the deal we have is to start we
Grant amnesty to those already here and
then we lock things down that's exactly
what Ronald Reagan did when he stabbed
us all in the back and I'm sick of these
these these conservatives who are like
Ronald Reagan was the best are you
kidding and they argue yeah but the
amnesty wasn't that many people look
what it did to California it's not just
California following this this is in the
' 80s into the 90s you end up with the
next generation of individuals when they
tried passing a proposition 187 in
California that said non-citizens cannot
have access to the public to public
goods it it led to protests in Mass re
Revol why because they brought in a
large portion of noncitizens granted
them citizenship and these non-citizens
have deeper ties to their families as
they should and they will always vote on
behalf of their families so instead of
getting people to immigrate here to
assimilate and integrate here they get a
bunch of people who broke the law to
enter this country grant them benefits
to our public goods then the right to
vote surprise surprise they voted on
behalf of their home countries and their
families which is completely
unsurprising anyone would do it with
this migrant crisis if there is not a
mass deportation if Mexico's demands are
fulfilled and Biden plays the same game
as Reagan that's it American values
getting raced overnight no I agree and I
think 10 million would be like the
eighth biggest state so no I I agree
with you a th% I think they are probably
going to do some sort of amnesty and
then it just flips all the voting
districts and I didn't realize that
California gets eight extra
congressionals
so there's there's estimates I think it
was um I'm not sure which organization a
few years ago there was in it says in
2020 when they're doing the new census
California loses a seat some estimates
said it's it's one or two seats perhaps
they get extra now those seats also mean
Electoral College votes yeah yeah
however with um this bill that I think
it wasn't uh uh drafted by Massie but it
was sponsored the Republicans actually
estimate 5 to seven extra electoral
votes for Democrats based on people are
not citizens this is the mistake made by
so many people we are not a democracy so
I was I don't know if you guys saw that
Zero Hedge debate with the CR Des
Destiny and Alex that was CRA Alex and
Destiny are a match made in heaven
because the way they just yell over each
other but in this Alex Jones correctly
points out it doesn't matter if they
vote what matters is this is a republic
in which case as long as Congress
represents non-citizens their vote is
rep their their their will is
represented the Federal level for the
president and for our laws and the only
thing the left were saying was illegal
immigrants don't vote illegal immigrants
don't vote over and over again that
doesn't matter we are a republic not a
democracy we vote for a representative
if a representative is is if if a
district is created because there's
750,000 non-citizens those non-citizens
get representation in Congress and then
they they effectively get their vote
yeah well and so yeah you're you're
exactly right they'll say well they
don't vote okay but they're presence
does sway elections their their presence
does affect elections they'll say other
things well they they don't receive
welfare benefits that's also not true
well I mean you guys are constantly
saying that taxes pay for churches
because church is not paying taxes but
their parishioners using public services
means that they're taking from the
system okay well guess what illegals
don't pay taxes and they take from the
system and you don't consider that to be
theft and on top of that they will have
one citizen in the family who can take
welfare living with five or 10 illegals
who are receiving the welfare from them
so yes illegals are rece approve free
healthcare in California for illegal IM
true let's pause here let's pause here
the Democrats argue that they don't they
either don't receive benefits or they're
paying in let me just stop you right
there and we'll go as rudimentary as we
can have you complained about potholes
lately yes more people means more wear
and tear on your roads someone's going
to pay for that the roads are going to
have to be fixed more frequently because
there's more people in your city that's
it so if you're wondering why it is your
water bill goes up if you're wondering
why it is that your the cost of electric
is going up it's because demand is
increasing quite a bit wear and tear is
increasing Ro there's going to be more
road construction there's going to be
more density density related problems
more students per classroom
Transportation more students per
classroom that's right more crowded
trains so if you are if you are the kind
I've heard from so many people remember
when what was it KFC filled the potholes
was it
KFC Resturant I think it was Domino know
it was like a delivery thing I got to
look into that let me let me check well
I think there's a guy that has like a
Tik Tok page where he goes and fixes
pool he has millions of followers
Kentucky Fried Chicken sponsored pothole
repairs Domino's did too Domino's did
they'd fill the hole and then they would
stamp their logo on the hole and say hey
we fixed this for you what what causes
these potholes what you end up there's a
lot of things that can cause potholes
but it's basically a lot of starting and
stopping you start and stop and then it
causes you know pressure hits and then
and huge trucks big trucks driving
the more people you bring into a city
and they're bringing them in in Mass
hundreds of thousands per month you will
see more wear and tear and you're going
to pay for that so when everyone was
complaining that we had pothole problems
that weren't being fixed to the point
where fast food companies started doing
it themselves as
advertising this is caused by higher
population density that's that's that's
it and if you're okay with paying the
bills and dealing with the stresses of
population density by all means but this
means there's going to be more crime
food's gonna be more expensive parking
will be non-existent it's already very
crowded in New York it's crazy now just
keep adding more people and see how that
goes I mean also we know for a fact that
they're not willing to pay any of the
costs associated with increased
migration they're just okay with people
who live in Border towns or in states
that are being flooded to have to pay
those costs as soon as they get imported
into their neighborhoods they freak out
and shoe all of them away they actually
call the National Guard and we saw that
in Martha's Vineyard yeah see Eric Adams
is suing the bus companies now instead
of going after the government I don't
know if you saw that he's suing the
actual coach sounds about right but he's
acting out of desperation I mean he just
can't do anything to save New York from
immigration except to to move IM illegal
immigrants to other counties in New York
that didn't want this to happen in the
first place I mean the reality is that
Republicans failed a long time ago by
not being more proactive about
immigration and now we're seeing the the
result of this and I think part of it is
that we have to take it more seriously
and not be afraid of the consequences of
that like the the big deter for a long
time was like oh these people need help
the we you know whatever I can
understand a compassionate response to
people who are legitimately stressed but
now the whole world knows that you can
come to America and say I am here to
claim Asylum and you don't need any
credible proof we'll schedule hear
hearing way later there's no evidence of
this I mean our immigration system makes
us weak and I don't understand why more
people wouldn't take that seriously they
want the country to be weak and that's
why they do take it seriously they're
very serious about ensuring the problem
gets worse yeah which is crazy I I think
this is what's so interesting about the
possible impeachment of aandra Yus which
is like he is derel in Duty right there
are laws in the book that his office is
actively fought against uh enforcing
there have been times that he you
remember the the the whipping story this
idea that like it was
ridiculous they were carrying whips they
were on a horse it was they did not whip
any migrants and Alandra mayorcas went
to Congress and was like it was crazy
and I I I denounced this and whatever
else he sold out border agents he's not
even representing the people in his
office or in his who are within his
purview to uh advocate for p and respect
who are trying to do the job that they
were asked to do I mean it's a system
that's completely designed to fail and
yet the Democrats are going to push for
it for longer I just don't get it at all
did you see in Brazil I think in 2024
you have to show that you have $2,000 in
your bank account to get a visa to go to
Brazil to to get a visa to go to Brazil
yes you need to show a bank bank sa that
$2,000 it makes sense I know they got
anybody in I know but that's no that's
real that's not conspiracy so yeah I
mean obviously we should have some sort
of regulations but I know people that
graduated from like SMU and TCU which
are schools in Dallas that were
International students that immediately
had to you know get the hell out of the
country so it's crazy that we kick out
the students but literally you can be
like a convicted you know pervert you
just have to come across the border and
say the right things and then they let
you and did you see how many migrants
are from Haiti they're like Haitian most
of them are not from Mexico majority are
the other thing Mexico is like we'll
help you but also we are not really
stopping anyone from entering our
country you you know theoretically with
a lot of the stuff if you're claiming
amesty you're supposed to stop in the
first country and it said they're like
yep keep going to America sounds great
fly to Canada enter through the northern
border thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net